Thank you guys for coming out today.
My name is Scott Bergman.
I'm part of the talks that Google program here in Ann Arbor and I have the
distinct privilege of welcoming doctors.
Jeff and Stan need to graph a to tell you guys a little bit about them.
I'll give you a little background.
Uh,
at 25,
Dr Jeff digraph became a senior executive at Domino's,
which became one of the fastest growing companies in America.
And not only that,
he became a professor at the Ross School of business here in Ann Arbor and has
become a SeeSuite advisor to over half of the fortune 500.
Not only that,
Jeff's ideas and innovation had been covered by the NPR and PBS where he has
been a featured columnist for inc wired fortunate in psychology today just to
name a few.
And we have staff need to graph here today who is the CEO of innovator eum a
consulting and training practice here.
And they also have offices in Atlanta and Ann Arbor.
And she's also an innovation community builder where she runs innovation
tournament's here in Detroit and is also the creator of the collaborative open
innovation network used by the University of Michigan.
All right guys,
well come on up.
We're happy to have you.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for joining us today.
Thanks Google.
Thanks for having us.
Thanks Scott.
So what I want to do today is I want to challenge a lot of,
uh,
probably your most sacred notions about innovation.
I'm going to tell you a little bit about my work and,
and,
uh,
what we know about how innovation actually produces value and destroys value.
Uh,
to do that,
it's going to be like an old western movie where we're going to start with the
long shot,
you know,
of,
of the city of dodge,
and then we're going to move into the tumbleweeds street.
Then finally we're going to look at,
uh,
the sheriff,
right?
We're gonna,
we're gonna talk about you.
So I want to start with a little backstory here.
Um,
I'm all,
both standing and I are technologists were trained as technologists that sort of
advanced degrees are in.
Um,
but interestingly enough,
whenever I'm a anywhere in an airport and I travel a lot,
somebody always wants to stop and tell me about new technology.
They have you heard about the latest thing,
and I'm sure you guys get this all the time and it's,
some of it's apocryphal,
you know,
that we're being,
it's I technologies coming from aliens and some of it's,
uh,
some of it's stuff that you've already seen your,
you're already know,
but,
but you all know that technology happens and the cycle of technology,
the magnitude will men of technology always increases over time.
And there's a bunch of laws about this.
I won't bore you with that.
But around,
uh,
around the late eighties,
I got a call from an editor at life magazine and she wanted to talk to me about
innovation.
So I thought she wanted to talk to me and she said,
no,
I want you to give a commentary.
We're writing a piece on the hundred most important people of the 20th century,
and one of them is related to you.
Now this was a huge surprise.
I don't know any,
most of the people related to me not doing so well.
Right.
So there she talked about this man named Charles Fair to graph and she sort of,
you know,
I was embarrassed.
I didn't know who this person was.
A No,
you know,
nobody told me about.
So when she got off the phone,
I looked him up and he,
the guy who created pocket books,
he created paperback books in the 1930s.
And his whole idea with this technology was that people would become literate if
books were cheap,
two bits people would become literate,
but they didn't.
And the reason it stuck with me,
I was doing a project with Alan Kay and Steve Jobs in the state of California to
try and develop literacy for people who are,
who are,
uh,
underserved.
And we the exact same result.
We didn't get any results from introducing technology into the situation.
And so very early on that began to galvanize my thoughts about culture and the
role of culture and technology and how in some ways,
culture overtakes or co ops technology.
So what I want to talk about today is that innovation isn't really an invention.
It's not just a gadget.
It's not,
you know,
it's not next.
The cool thing,
it actually has a lot to do with identifying patterns,
how those patterns go together,
identifying how culture and compency interact with those patterns.
And I want to give some examples of that,
but I want to start with this whole notion of dominant logic and it's a really
big thing for Google and you're getting a lot of sort of press negative press
about this and that is one of the things that goes on in our world.
We sometimes call it this in business microsegmentation the notion is we have a
tendency to identify in value people who are like us,
right?
That's kind of one of the big challenges and when social media started,
I started writing articles that got a lot of negative attention saying that I
wasn't sure that social media was really a creating this kind of inclusive
society that in some ways it was micro segmenting us.
The people who are your friends,
even though they might look different and they may seem different,
they actually believe all the same nonsense you believe.
And if they don't believe it,
what do you do?
You on a dark night,
on a dark road,
you unfriend them.
The Spanish inquisition couldn't have thought of this.
So the notion is we get these very vertical segments.
So if you've ever talked to anybody about religion or politics,
you know what I mean by the whole notion of dominant logic.
And it comes back to what they crazy philosopher Schopenhauer said,
uh,
you know,
over a century ago,
every man,
every person takes the limits of his own field division for the limits of the
world.
And that's kind of where we're at.
Now.
I'm going to make the argument that this is the problem of modernity and there's
a way to solve this,
to get over this.
So the key is how do we get beyond this dominant logic?
How do we develop a mindset to actually be more inclusive?
And I'm going to talk about inclusiveness in a way that's very different than
you've probably heard it because it's not just politically correct.
It's not just morally correct.
It's essential for innovation.
I'm going to prove it to you now.
It turns out that every organization has to do two things,
and boy,
Google,
this is really relevant to you.
The first thing an organization has to do is maintain itself.
It has to.
Pr had asked to produce predictable outcomes.
This is why capitalism requires capitalists.
Whether you're a private equity,
whether it's publicly traded,
somebody asked to show that you're going to do things on a normal basis.
In the way that that happens is we get rid of variants.
We create standards.
We call this operating rhythm.
Right now,
the notion is that makes us,
that makes us all predictable,
but the problem is just like people,
we want to grow,
so to grow,
instead of eliminating deviants,
what we need to do is introduce it.
So innovation by definition is a form of deviants.
And so we're going to have this tension and it's not a tension of type.
It's not I'm an ENTP or an inf Jay.
It's not that.
It's one form of value actually literally assaults.
The other one form of value destroys the other.
I want you to think about high growth economies versus high quality or
productive economies.
They're oppositional and there's a reason one is creating standards and one is
creating deviance.
Now I'm going to say something that's going to seem very radical to you.
This tension when used properly is actually not only good,
it's the basis of the growth engine.
So let me give you some examples of culture and how culture co-op's technology.
Interestingly enough,
everybody talks about Tesla and it's a great technology and I love Tesla,
but here's the problem.
Tesla last year sold 55,000 cars and they lost $600 million.
Now they're not going to lose $600 million going forward and they're going to
sell maybe twice as many cars,
but the notion is we've had some soft quarters in the automobile industry,
haven't we?
Tesla hasn't destroyed the automobile industry,
right?
What's affecting the automobile industry is over.
Now.
I want you to think about it over for a minute.
Where's the Innovation Uber ride sharing?
I'm an old guy.
We had ride sharing when I was a kid.
You called the parish priest.
You called the coach,
got a ride.
Look at the APP that they use.
Doesn't it look like the 2007 over the road trucking app?
It's not a particularly well run company.
There's all kinds of legal problems with it.
Where's the innovation and Uber?
Young people like you will get in the car with a stranger,
right?
It's a social innovation.
I won't.
It's like airbnb.
All of the sudden the car is not just something you drive.
It's something you take someone in Airbnb.
If someone came to my house,
I,
I have a nice house on the Huron River and use my towel.
I take it in the backyard,
burn it and buried.
I'd sick as dogs on them.
Right?
The notion is this social form of innovation has co-opted this.
Same is true for Goldman Sachs.
Anybody remember about four years ago,
not even for three years ago,
the number one selling book on the New York Times nonfiction book was
nonfiction.
List was a book called Flash Boys by Michael Lewis.
It was about spread networks.
The notion was Goldman Sachs and credit Suisse,
we're trading a little faster than you or could trade,
so they got the uplift on a stock and they got to sell,
get rid of the stock.
They've got to short the stock is it started to go down.
Now think of it this way,
there.
The bookie doesn't matter where they're Michigan or Ohio state,
when's the book?
He always makes money.
That's what this deal was and everyone said the fix is in.
The 1% is going to get richer and richer until what started happening until
cryptocurrency started to come in and that's what you young people right now.
Where do cryptocurrency start and don't say the 98 paper.
That's not where it started.
Where it really started was in money laundering.
It started with drug cartels.
Where does streaming really started?
I mean an earnest.
Where did that new technology come from?
The porn industry,
right?
Where did EMOJI started?
It started in terrorist cells.
So one of the things I want to point out right off the bat is that technologies
are often used,
are first adapted by groups that they're not intended for.
Anybody.
See the problem that happened in Amazon right before Christmas,
there's a little recommendation engine,
the little problem that showed up in the New York Times.
If you like fertilizer,
you might like black powder and ball bearings,
right?
The notion is technology is powerful.
When we start looking at people who are making the smartphone's going back a
decade,
it's only been a decade.
The in their wildest dreams,
they never imagined that you would use the camera to take pictures of yourself.
They thought you'd be at Yellowstone and taking the vistas and things like that.
So culture has this mitigating factor where what you want technology to do is
completely different.
And think about the 13 indictments two weeks ago that Mueller has made.
So the notion is this culture piece is not only confounding,
it actually does something more powerful.
And the biggest industry to look at for this right now is pharmaceuticals.
The pharmaceutical industry is reeling.
Why is it really,
because all of these big pharmaceutical companies are all of the sudden having
to compete with young people like yourself who've got together in a federation
deal and they have names like bios forum and the open and firestorm and things
like that.
And what they're doing is to developing medications and therapies and drugs and
their open source of patenting them.
Right?
So the notion is,
here's the question,
I was at Duke the other day and I was talking to them to their law school and I
said,
where are all your lawyers going these days?
Cause it's tough to get a job if you're a lawyer.
And they said pharmaceuticals.
Well the answer is simple.
What are they doing in pharmaceuticals?
They're trying to protect their intellectual property.
Here becomes the question for you.
Who's going to win this bar fight?
Is it going to be the millions of people who are trying to do things for free in
this open source?
Or is it going to be a handful of sort of these very monopolistic kind of
companies that are trying to protect the intellectual property.
That's why we're seeing these companies start in places that don't have strong
intellectual property laws,
Tanzania,
places like that,
parts of the Philippines,
Sabu other kinds of places.
So I want to take a step back.
So there's this big trend,
this trend towards technology coming out of places and people doing different
things with it because of culture.
And then this other big trend of the challenge between organizations trying to
control things.
We're going to call this,
uh,
we're going to call this a longitude and organization's network and we're going
to call this latitude,
right?
Longitude and latitude of organizations.
Well,
how does innovation actually relate to all this?
This has to start with,
what's our definition about 1993 I got to write the definition for the federal
government for innovation.
And all I did was coopt a very famous definition from innovation from the 1960s
from Marshall Mcluhan.
Mcluhan said innovation has four attributes.
He said,
first of all,
and innovation enhances something.
Well here we are.
Google.
Were you the first search engine?
No.
What did you,
you know,
did you have the same sort of format as other search engines know you had little
box and what Google made better was not so much.
It was a faster search or a better search.
At the beginning.
It was an easier search.
It was a simpler search,
right?
So you made it better by simplifying it.
Now the second thing is an innovation has to eliminate something.
What is the innovation kill?
Now,
that's a tough one,
right?
I want you to think about what it,
Charles Schwab killed.
Everybody.
Remember brokerage houses,
the big brokerage houses in on fifth avenue down on Wall Street.
They're all gone.
Now the EF Hutton,
the quiet companies really quiet.
Why?
Because we disintermediated the broker.
Basically.
We let trading happen directly.
Course.
This is an industry.
You have a lot of interest in.
A lot of,
uh,
a lot of stakes in the ground here.
It has to return us to something.
Here's an interesting one.
It has to make us feel like we're like,
we're,
do we need to do something here?
We're okay.
All right.
So it has to make us feel like we're returning to something.
So think about it.
What are the big trends in restaurants right now?
Is it faster food or is it slow food?
Whole food.
Farm to table,
right?
And the ultimate,
the ultimate returning us to something we feel we lost was developed about two
blocks that direction,
which was Viagara right there.
25 again.
And finally,
the most important thing McLuhan said,
and I've got your little logo up here,
right?
The most important thing called McLuhan said he's just said over time and
innovation reverses into its opposite the anti innovation.
Does anybody remember when,
when email was going to set you free?
Anybody remember that?
Yeah.
And now what?
We're all slaves,
right?
We can't put her phone down.
We're all slaves to email and,
and,
and a SMS and everything else.
Now I'm going to add a few things to McCullough.
Number one,
innovation is a form of useful novelty.
All that means is it can happen anywhere.
Innovation can happen anywhere.
So I want you to think about Starbucks for a minute.
It's a commodity.
The Egyptians had it.
It's something that's been around for 3000 years.
Where's,
where's the innovation?
And Starbucks will,
it's theater,
right?
It's the whole experience of going to Starbucks and they have names for
everything.
Innovation pays in the future.
It's what's called a convex form of value.
How much data do we have in the future?
Anyone?
How much data?
So I'm coming home from Shanghai the other day and this guy sitting next to me
says,
the dollar,
is it going up or down?
I said,
it's going down.
He said,
why do you say that?
And I said,
because it's up.
That's a currencies.
Do they go up and down?
Duh.
And he said,
what?
He said when and I said,
I don't know it.
If I knew when I'd be George Soros,
I'd be speculating the dollar.
And I sure wouldn't be telling a pathetic loser like you about the dollar.
So the point is,
the biggest form of resistance to innovation is excessive planning or getting
stuck in the planning cycle.
Have you been to the meeting about the meeting?
Have you seen the report about the report?
Yeah.
You're the big guys now.
You used to be the small guys,
right?
So someone else is running an experiment right now where you're doing that.
And finally,
innovations have a shelf life.
They go sour like milk.
So the other day I'm in Chicago,
I'm giving the keynote speech for the American Medical Association.
I'm feeling pretty good about this.
It's a big,
it's a big meeting,
but I notice on Michigan Avenue,
the line goes all the way down Michigan Avenue.
And I'm thinking,
Holy Mackerel,
there's a lot of people here,
here.
My silly talk about innovation.
And then it occurs to me what's being released.
The new apple iPhone is being released and they're basically in line to get the
new iPhone.
Of course,
what happens to the old iPhone?
The minute the new iPhone is introduced,
it's rubbish,
right?
It's discounted.
It's falls off the commodity cycle.
So the big challenge of innovation is it's only an innovation for a moment in
time.
So this is what an innovation is,
which means it can happen in the supply chain,
can happen in marketing,
can happen.
The product itself.
It's a lot more than the gadget.
So there's other mythologies I think that people have about innovation.
I wanted to spell your first of all innovative organizations have very little in
common.
When we start looking at the indexes for innovations,
and there's about,
there's about seven that started and there's about 13 legitimate ones.
Now there's hundreds of other ones,
but let's say on a 13 ones,
there's about 15% of the companies that they have in common,
which tells you right off the bat that they're not talking about the same thing
too.
Money is almost never a barrier to innovation.
Now,
if you know this,
one of the big issues is money often creates a constraint when you have less
money that you have to have an interesting work around.
And we can talk about how the economy is flushed with money right now because
the tax cut and all the repatriation of the money is going to put about a
trillion,
maybe $2 trillion back in this economy.
So the notion is,
is this really going to go to innovation?
Is it going to go to stock,
buy back it?
Is it going to go to private equity?
Where's the money going to go?
Competitors often compete in opposite ways.
So this is one that relates to you.
Google,
you have how many companies now?
58 59 companies,
right?
You make everything.
You are open source man,
right?
Apple.
What apple makes,
what?
They make nothing,
right?
Foxconn and invitation and a consortium of companies make Apple's product.
They make design and they make brilliant designs.
You have to give that to apple.
And the other thing that makes,
they make a closed operating system,
right?
The,
in their ecosystem,
it's not just different than yours,
it's almost oppositional,
right?
One's playing offense,
one's playing defense.
So,
so the whole idea that people,
even in the same kind of in a venn diagram,
you not in the exact same industry but in related industries compete the same
way.
They don't.
Incumbents are almost never first movers.
This is what you have to worry about Google,
right?
Think about it as a bar fight.
Anybody from a blue collar neighborhood like I am anybody from a blue car,
Nigga,
you're from the same neighborhood I am.
Right?
The notion is who throws a is a big guy with the Budweiser jacket or is it the
little guy with crazy eyes is the little guy.
We called this in business first mover advantage and this is why startups throw
the first punch because they can't compete on scope or scale.
So when I start looking at what's happened with Google,
I think your cap value this morning,
he's like $680 billion.
I think you're the second or third most valuable company in the world.
You're no longer a startup and the real challenge here is what getting you to
act like you're a startup.
I looked at your new building,
your beautiful building.
I see all the trappings.
Remember I built dominoes.
I help build Domino's in the 1980s which was the fastest growing company in the
world in the 1980s the interesting thing is at some point you're going to have
that real challenge of maintenance versus growth.
It turns out that breakthrough happens at the edges of the bell curve.
We'll talk about that later because that's a very important point and this is a
point that stand he's going to talk about,
which is when we started looking at innovation index is in 1993 less than 1% of
them on a regular basis beat the growth benchmark on Wall Street.
So the notion is most of what you believe about innovation is untrue.
And we're going to talk about why it's untrue.
There's only one thing that we're pretty sure we know about innovation and this
is going to be the key to the whole discussion today.
And that is diversity happens in the 30 to 50 places on the planet that produce
almost all the intellectual property.
And when we look at these places,
whether it's Televiv,
whether it's part of Shanghai,
whether it's a Anarbor Michigan or whether it's Palo Alto,
where you know Cary,
North Carolina,
wherever you're at,
one of the things you're going to see is it looks very different than any place
if you drove 40 miles outside of the city boundaries,
right?
And one of the things we see is that people are very different.
I'm going to talk about why that's so important.
Now remember the whole idea that I started with talking about the magnitude of
innovation and the momentum or the speed and magnitude.
The two things you have to think about is how much and how fast.
That's the question you always must ask yourself,
how much innovation,
how fast is a meteor careening towards the earth?
It's going to kill us all.
We better do something now.
Or is it that the the ice caps are melting and we probably should do something
in the next four or five years in order to get our handle on this?
Right?
Maybe it's even a little more urgent than that,
who knows?
But the first thing that companies do is they build a process.
Now here's a question to you.
Does process create deviance or eliminate deviance?
What is process do it eliminates deviance.
Yeah,
so the first thing we do to make innovation happen is what we built something to
eliminate innovation.
And this is what we do in business schools.
This is stage gating.
This is portfolio man.
But these are hurdle rates.
So the notion is we're trying to gain control because what we really want from
innovation is what we want to predictable revenue.
We want predictable things.
So by definition,
when you build a process,
you're going to be incremental because that's what processes are designed to do.
That's what that tool is designed to do.
Now,
what if we really wanted to do something with much higher magnitude for
innovation?
Wouldn't we have to change the gene pool?
It's like a great sports team or an orchestra or a band or a great chef when we
have to go out and get people right?
How long did it take to,
to,
to develop a tremendous innovator here at Google a long time or a professor at
Michigan or Stanford or Harvard or wherever you are,
wherever you came from,
wherever you are.
So the notion is this type of innovation is much higher but harder to do.
That's why Google spends a lot of money on you developing you.
Cause that's really important.
We do the same thing at Michigan.
Now.
Finally,
if I really,
really want to change culture,
what I,
if I really want to change the culture to make innovation happen,
is that going to happen overnight?
It takes forever.
Now I'm going to say something that's really controversial.
There's only two ways to change culture because culture isn't a thing you can
touch.
Culture is in the ether cultures,
the way you talk,
it's their mindset.
It's the,
it's the,
it's the way you interact.
It's not a thing.
Culture is contained in two things.
Number one is contained in leadership.
How you lead,
what do we do if you're acquiring an underperforming from what is the first step
when you acquire an underperforming from your it there,
right knuckle bump,
you'd get rid of the senior suite.
The Chinese have a wonderful saying.
The fish stinks from the head.
They have a wonderful saying for everything,
but that's what that means.
That means you got to get rid of people because culture is contained in
leadership and if you've got great leaders,
you get golden handcuffs.
Oh,
they're going to stay for two or three years.
The second thing that changes culture is how you work.
Now,
I worked on a project that most of you know is ecoimagination.
It's the first $30 billion spend on the green technology that General Electric
did.
Well,
one of the things that people get wrong about that is it was not just to,
to,
uh,
to change the game about a power which w which was partially,
but it was also to try and figure out how to get 28 divisions of one of the
world's largest companies to work in sync.
So you either change how people lead or you change how they work.
That's how culture gets changed,
but it takes a long time.
So the issue is we all know what's required,
but are we willing to put the time?
And so
what's the answer?
Well,
one of my favorite answers comes from an old,
uh,
an old philosophy called the doubt.
And you're going to see that a lot of my,
a lot of,
um,
of,
of my work and standees work really relates from this old Chinese idea that's
about 200 years before Plato is around.
People start writing about this and at the heart of the Dow is the notion of the
Yin and the Yang construct.
The notion that there are conflicting forces in the universe and these
conflicting forces produce hybrids.
They create new ways of doing things.
Well from this,
the Chinese have done something remarkable.
I've spent a lot of time in China over the years.
The Chinese had developed a,
a a way of thinking called the chain and it's called something,
it's called the book of changes.
People use it for,
uh,
you know,
like for predicting the future,
but it's really used so that people can think through all the options that
they've got.
This is sometimes called heuristics are cognitive algorithms.
Finally,
out of this,
there's a lot of how to books and the most famous one is a book called the art
of War,
right?
Written by Sun Tzu.
Whether that was a real person or not,
it's a real controversy.
Right?
And then finally that family household,
how to use this day in and day out will function way.
Right?
The whole notion of build upon the whole notion of having a compass to put this
together and what it means is you don't have to have inputs and outputs and
process because you're thinking the way I'm thinking and you're looking at all
the options so I don't have to supervise you and tell you what to do.
Well,
this is the heart of our thinking and this is the heart of our book.
We had this sort of revelation in the early 1990s and that was the most
innovative companies when we start looking at predictability of what was going
to make an innovative company were companies that had constructive conflict.
Now this is important because when I talk about constructive conflict,
I'm not talking about talking disrespectfully to people.
That's not what I mean.
I don't mean marginalizing people.
I mean we have fond regard,
filial piety,
collegial piety for each other.
Hopefully we have,
we like each other,
maybe love each other,
but it means when it comes to ideas,
we engage.
Now,
engagement usually means we talked about engagement.
Oh,
you really like being here at work.
No.
When we start looking at innovation means you have an idea and I have an idea
and their different ideas.
Instead of being on social media and are sniping at each other as trolling each
other,
I'm going to engage you.
I'm going to skid nose to nose you and say,
I think it should be like this,
and you're going to say,
I think it needs to be like this.
Now this is what a caution to millennials.
This is not an opportunity for Q four for compromise.
This is trying to push this to the new place.
The next idea,
the third way,
a new way.
This becomes the generative power of innovation where you do it.
I'll think about it for me to think about the healthcare debate,
I got to get my Ted talk when President Obama rolled out.
The affordable healthcare act at the White House is great.
The problem is you've got one group that says you should all be public,
and the other group says it should all be private.
Are those really are options,
aren't the options,
everything in between and how do we take that forward,
right?
We spend $1 trillion basically yelling at each other,
yelling over the fence.
So my point about social media is we haven't had conflict.
We've had yelling at each other,
but no one is engaged.
Everybody following us.
So the thing is we're going to engage ideas.
So there,
there is no such thing as a safe place.
It means if we talk respectfully,
we're going to engage.
And this means that the heart of innovation is this concept of diversity.
So diversity is more than just a moral issue.
And of course it is a moral issue,
but it's more,
and it's not just the color of your skin,
it's not,
it's your belief system,
it's your cognitive maps,
it's how you interact at your profession.
So to do this standing and I build our model on Quinn and Cameron's monitor.
Bob Quinn had been here I believe,
and he was sort of one of my mentors along with CK pro a lot.
And Rudolf Arnheim,
um,
Quinn,
this is their model called the competing values framework.
We took it toward the innovation direction,
did a lot of research on it over the past 30 years.
And it's a often referred to as the innovation genome.
If you read the popular literature,
the Innovation Code,
so were the developers of that,
and it basically says there are four types of innovators and they compete
against each other.
And the,
the key to innovation is following these,
these kitty corner competitions and looking for hybrids.
So I'm going to explain what each of these means in just a minute,
but to put it,
to put it simply,
innovation has longitude and latitude.
There are two continuums of which you have to look at.
And if you can figure out those two continuums,
the most important thing are the dynamics between the opposites.
Now I want to emphasize this is not an opposite of type.
This is not an opposite of style.
This is what you're trying to create,
destroys what I'm trying to create.
So when quality goes up,
you reduce errors,
right?
And innovation goes down.
When innovation goes up,
I introduce errors.
This is sometimes called economy at risk,
right?
So there's a trade off.
What we're saying is when these two things show up together,
what we've learned in our research is those stocks over time,
outperform all the other stocks,
right?
And they outperform.
The index is that people have,
so these conflicts are going to become central.
So let me talk a little bit about the conflicts.
Now.
First of all,
this is not just about you.
I like to call these Russian Patricia,
the Russian nesting dolls,
right?
I don't know.
Do you do this?
I read self help books and then I go,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to go to Trevor City and I'm going to,
I'm going to just going to quit my job and I'm going to,
I'm going to write a crappy science fiction novels.
There's what I'm doing and I've worked hard in my life,
made a little money.
I'm doing okay.
I'm chucking it all.
That's what I'm doing.
You're going to get to that point.
I've had enough of this.
Yeah,
but there's another nesting doll on mine,
nesting doll.
It's called,
I married and I have three children and I have a dean and I business partners
and I have people who count on me.
Right?
Yeah.
That's the other part.
And then what happens after that is there's the real world.
That's the big nesting doll.
There's a pandemic,
there's war,
there's financial crisis.
Boy,
you young people got blown out.
Bad.
No,
wait,
I,
that was pretty bad.
Yeah.
The notion is you don't act alone,
do you?
You Act in accordance to your community and you act in accordance to the
situation.
So it's not about you.
It's not about I'm this type and that's all equal.
That's not what's going on.
What's going on is they're situational effectiveness and it's not situation like
this is awkward,
like it's a social situation.
It's like what's happening in the outside world and how do you need to act to do
this?
It's like playing a sports game,
like football or soccer,
whatever you follow.
There's a time that you do a certain sort of things because it's appropriate to
do it at times.
Surgeons the same way.
So let's look at the first one.
The first one is the creative type or the artist type.
I was really lucky when I was young.
I got to be an advisor to Steve Jobs.
It was great.
Uh,
you know,
Walt Disney was one of my heroes.
Anybody like Disney,
you know,
other than he had hit some opinions that were not very cool,
but he did some cool stuff.
Um,
think about,
uh,
Elan Musk,
think about Tesla,
not just a company,
but the Nicky Tesla and all that kind of stuff.
So what's interesting about this type of person is that they're very good in
unique situations.
Things we haven't seen before.
We're trying to cure an incurable disease.
We're going into a battle.
That situation we've never seen before.
You know,
as meteors careening towards the earth,
it's highly unique so that you're making it up as you go along.
There isn't really a lot of precedents for these people.
They have a high tolerance for ambiguity,
love ambiguity,
right?
They love to spread the field.
They love to try stuff.
My favorite example of this is the large Hadron collider.
Anybody remember three years ago,
the Bose,
the God particle,
right here we are,
and at cern in Switzerland we have seven Nobel prize winners to believe it will
create a black Fisher.
Do you remember this?
They thought it would create a black hole and destroy the universe.
They bet a beer and pulled the switch.
See you in hell.
You're again,
these are these guys.
They're going to drive the Harley end of the pool.
Right?
But they're going to see the future first cause they're looking for it.
So the organizations are very ad hoc.
They're making it up as they go along,
they're morphing.
People are coming.
They're going into these organizations and the artists themselves,
what they really want is they want to be creative.
There's serial monogamous.
They don't like staying in their job.
They're always looking at a new thing.
They're all add.
Every last one of them,
they pick up every pretty pebble on the beach.
You know what I mean?
This is that.
It's a Fellini movie.
This is that group.
It's a grateful dead concert.
You know,
Jerry's playing,
Mickey's in the bus,
the girl and the white dress has had too many mushrooms and she spinning,
you know the spinners.
So you're probably too young to remember all this.
That's what's going on here.
This is this group of people.
So they're have a high degree of innovation,
but their speed is relatively moderate because the,
the,
the delta is very large sums what's going to happen tomorrow.
Others when hell freezes over.
But the biggest problem is they're high risk.
Right?
Hold that bloat up.
Are you good?
Do you remember last fall,
space x blew up $1 billion rocket and they blew Facebook's rocket to it.
The t o that blown up.
Yeah.
How about that?
This is this group of people.
So where we find them,
we find them taking risks,
we find them in strategy,
we find them in the arts.
I bet some of you want it to be in the arts and you sort of are in the arts,
aren't ya?
Right.
Look at the,
I look at sheepish looks because what you really want is freedom and you're held
together by your vision.
Right?
So one of the things I learned real early in being around these people,
the early days of Silicon Valley where these visionaries who used to be like
follow the dead or Ski Bums,
right?
And then they built these companies including your own,
And how the opposite of this group can engage this group is do things like
understand that this group is going to try and make problems bigger,
not smaller.
This group doesn't want an answer.
They want to,
they want to play.
So bring a fifth of Jack Daniels and some crayons.
You're going to do some color in,
right?
This is this group.
They're never going to be on time,
right?
They,
they,
they're these,
these are these people right now the opposite are the responsible people,
the engineers,
I call them autonomous man.
I'm monogamous,
man.
I've thought of it coming in here today.
It came fully formed from my forehead,
like Athena and they quietly sing hi Ho.
Hi.
These are these guys.
They know the right way and wrong way to do things and they'll point it out to,
they love to tell you,
you know,
Jeff,
that's the wrong way to do that.
I'm on all these famous journals and all these other journals,
guys in the journal loved to tell me all the stuff I'm not doing right.
You know,
Jeff,
you didn't have value.
I'm like,
I got it.
Okay.
We wear funny hats.
We have medieval ceremonies,
the whole nine yards.
So these people are going to be unpredictable situations where there's a lot of
scale and failure's not an option.
You're gonna see three things scale,
right?
We're,
we're,
we're selling a lot of something.
Whereas he complexity,
think about Boeing and the new,
the new 87th as 2 million moving parts.
And,
and the whole notion is,
you know,
you sent,
you bring that down the wrong way.
It goes,
Kaboom.
Bad things happen.
You operate the wrong way.
You send the young men,
and when women off to combat bad things happen.
Now,
interestingly enough,
my favorite example predictables Mcdonald's,
some illiterate kid presses a cheeseburger button and simultaneously somebody
shoots a cow and Argentina Bang and everything in between happens in Smithers
come here.
These are these guys,
right?
They want everything door.
And ironically in Google as an Amazon,
a lot of your success is here.
It's not in the green,
it's here,
right?
You're running a back office.
Very intricate supply chain is what you're doing with algorithms all over the
place.
So it's all about efficiency and quality.
Where the other one was about innovation and growth,
radical innovation and growth.
This is innovation to make things more efficient and make it work.
And the people who run this,
we're going to call them engineers.
It's all about security and productivity,
right?
The whole idea of doing the right way and the wrong way.
So you see that these are quite different than from each other.
So these people are very good where there's large scale projects.
We're going to build something really big like this whole campus up here,
uh,
Google,
and we're going to have a right way and a wrong way.
We're going to get these people who have have technical degrees,
engineering,
medicine,
the sciences,
and what these people want is they want responsibility because what they seek is
they seek process and the reason they use process is because what they have to
do is take the vision that the artist has and they have to materialize it.
They have to build the stupid thing.
Right.
And it's an la artists.
One of the things you love to tell the engineers is it's 80% done.
What's it really mean?
It's 20% done on a good day.
You're not.
Any of the artists will take credit for everything,
don't they?
Engineer?
They take credit.
Yeah.
That's the way the artists are.
They crow about it.
So what you can do artists when dealing with an engineer one show up on time,
you know,
you think they don't notice,
oh,
the engineers are the most passive aggressive group you got here.
And on a dark night on a dark road,
you'll disappear.
They got a file on you.
Like j Edgar Hoover,
right.
They've absolutely watch you,
right?
No look good.
Yeah.
You know this right?
The notion is look at the data,
actually read the data,
right?
How about that for a change in follow the accepted form and in the book there's
a lot of the keys about this.
Now here's the point.
The point is the success of this group comes down to your ability to partner
with the opposite.
So the first thing I'm telling you is on a very personal level,
the person who makes you crazy is probably what's missing in your ability to
grow as a person and your ability to add value to the organization.
So when he following us,
number two,
you have to manage appropriately to the outcome you want.
So if I want the engineer outcome,
I have to use process.
It's complicated.
If I want the artist outcome,
I'm going to change the gene pool and I'm going to hedge.
That's why startups run the way they do because they can't compete on scope or
scale.
So the notion is I,
I've got a screwdriver or a hammer or a wrench and a saw,
they're great tools,
they're not interchangeable.
And that becomes the first challenge.
Now we have to encounter the other.
That's the key.
I want you to think about your own organization.
Think about Larry and Serge.
You see this,
they're opposite Lennon and Mccartney,
right?
You're going to see this over and over again.
You have to find the person that makes you crazy.
So I liked superheroes.
So this is Johnny Storm,
the the flame.
Incidentally,
superheroes need to be more inclusive.
I couldn't find any sort of balance superheroes,
so I'm sorry about that.
But we'll have to get Stan Lee to work on that a little more.
Maybe some of the newer ones I don't know about.
And then we got to Richard's here.
Who sort of the red,
the red genius guy.
Well,
let's turn this around and talk about,
uh,
one of my favorite groups,
which is the compete group,
the blues.
These are the athletes I teach at the school of business where we grade on a
curve,
right?
And we have sayings like,
don't send your ducks to Eagle School.
And it's like the University of Chicago or Wharton or Mit,
right?
The whole notion is it's competitive.
That what we're trying to develop our athletes,
people who are positive.
There go forward moving.
But the notion is they're ready to compete.
They're ready to do what needs to be done.
So these are people who are very good in contentious situations.
So last week I was the keynote speaker at the air force,
their big annual convention,
right?
You want athletes in your military services,
Because what their job is,
what is to keep everybody safe.
That's their job.
So they're going to be aggressive and demanding situations.
So whether you're a sports team and it's Michigan competing against Ohio state,
or whether you're competing for potato chips or you're making smart phones,
this is where there's someone else coming after you,
right?
And we always make fun of these people until we need them.
They only need them.
Then we then all,
then it's all different deal,
right?
These are Mbas,
these are business people,
right?
And they're very market based organizations,
meaning they face outside and they're beholden to shareholders,
or they'd be holding the guidance.
They have something that they've told people they're gonna accomplish.
So they're very interested on speed and profitability.
The notion of profitability even in a nonprofit is are,
you know,
have we got bigger endowment?
You know,
Michigan likes to say,
you know,
we're not interested in that.
But of course the truth is all the best schools have what they have these huge
endowments,
right?
And that's kind of the score.
And finally these people are all about vitality and prosperity.
And you must have some of these people because I'm walking around your building,
you've got a gym and people are tracking how,
you know,
how far are they fit and are they doing stuff and who's in first place and who's
in last place and top 10 and bottom 10 so you're not fooling me,
Google,
you've got these guys too.
And we need these people.
We're going to find these people and a lot of places we're going to find them.
Wherever the challenge is,
results driven,
these are get it done people and they get it done very quickly.
These are not long cycle people.
So they're going to look where the goals are focused.
Like we have to make the quarter where we got a problem,
we've got to solve something.
Didn't work and it's got to work,
but more importantly,
more importantly,
we're going to find these people where challenges in resources result in some
kind of a score.
Now,
what the sages can do,
this is going to be an interesting thing because I have to warn you about blues
boomers in the United States are typically blues.
You know what?
When I came to college,
I came to college as a wrestler.
I got got to come to college as a wrestler and that meant somebody got a gold
medal and the rest of you were pathetic losers and either went to therapy or
learn to drink.
That's what it was.
That my generation,
you ever watched the Rudolph,
the red nose reindeer thing at Christmas and you think Santa Claus is a total
jerk?
Yeah,
that's,
that's my generation,
right?
We went to the moon.
We look the commies,
we built the net,
right?
That's us.
But our children are not those people.
Our children have a little trouble with our goal.
Centricity,
our focus on goals,
why we're obsessed with goals,
how,
why we compete and fight over.
Everything's very confusing.
Well,
our children are these sages and sages collaborate so they're very good at
cooperative of of the lifestyle things.
They're very good at searching and reapplying ideas.
They're very good at sharing,
right?
They don't like the idea of intellectual property.
They don't like the idea that somebody owns something asymmetries.
They have a very democratic notion of the world.
Very inclusive,
a very consensus notion of the world in general.
Right?
In general,
these are generalities.
Interestingly enough,
their organizations are very clannish,
very community oriented,
very network oriented,
so you're connecting to people that you want to connect with the you share some
kind of personal affinity for your very values oriented,
right?
Where the boomers are goal oriented,
your values oriented and I believe this is creating the largest cultural shift
in my lifetime.
It's not like the 60s I want to tell you three things about young people that
you probably already know.
Over half of all live births to women under the age of 30 starting in 2014 or
outside of marriage.
The more educated the woman is,
the less likely she is to marry.
Marriage is no longer normative.
I had been married forever,
right?
She's been married to me forever.
Right?
The notion of what you want to do for a living here at Google is this a lifetime
event at Google,
you are going to be your forever,
interestingly enough,
according to the Pew Charitable Trust,
what do you really want out of life?
You want to have impact,
you want to make meaning you want to take time off to cure river blindness in
Tanzania because you care about co co culture,
right?
As opposed to my generation.
And finally,
the other thing that's very big is we ask young people what their religious
affiliation is.
The number one growth areas.
What?
No affiliation,
right?
So if you're talking to a boomer,
I've been married forever,
right?
I'm a practicing Roman Catholic and I'm a capitalist pig,
To teach in a business school.
So we're different about this.
It doesn't mean we can't get along and it doesn't mean we don't have a lot to
teach each other.
But the notion is,
and it's,
I'm doing this in a very gross way.
Obviously it's sort of teach this,
but I also want to point out that the Chinese are a clannish culture.
They're the opposite of American culture.
American culture became American culture in a very ballistic way,
in a very hard way.
I want you to think about 2008 September 15th when Lehman crashed,
between September 15th of January one we laid off 6 million people.
Bang,
Bang.
Right?
But we also hired him back faster.
This culture doesn't write,
takes care of people because the valley's centric,
but also takes longer to bring it back.
So it's a long cycle culture.
We find these people and community service places where our conflict is managed.
We find these people where we're,
we're dealing with people in a way that we're trying to,
we're trying to help them develop.
We're trying to mitigate,
uh,
we're trying to mitigate conflicts and we're going to find these people where,
where harmony is paramount,
where people are respecting each other in a way that they don't,
they don't have the kind of conflicts that I'm suggesting here.
So how can the athletes engage people,
athletes,
boomers like me,
we have to be more patient.
That's a big one,
you know,
because you've got a lot of things that you'll say,
I need more time on this.
And if you're a boomer,
what boomers said,
oh,
you don't have more time.
So on Wednesday we have to be more,
uh,
it co cheerful with you.
You know,
how,
uh,
people will say you can do it.
There's all this big thing of a positivity now and what are of old boomers like
me thinking,
no,
you suck.
You can't sit down.
Right?
That's what we're thinking.
But no,
you're encouraged.
So we have to be understanding of that.
Right?
And of course,
I'm dealing in,
in,
uh,
in gross generalities here.
But the notion is the challenge here,
the other thing that predicts value is that these two things get along.
And that's one of the secrets I think to when my generation and your generation
collaborate when Americans and Chinese collaborator,
I think there's something very powerful that happens in those communities.
So I think of this like sue storm and the thing I'd sue storms are my favorite
ones.
She could,
she has a force field.
How many like a force field,
she can read your mind.
That's what I want to do.
Read your mind,
read my kid's mind,
protect them.
Right?
And then the thing just smashes stuff.
I'm sorry that my generation is kind of the thing saying we apologize but things
need to be smashed every now and then.
So there is a whole worldview here.
I'm not going to spend any time on this,
but this is not sort of pop psychology.
There's a lot of work about how you think about time,
how you think about space,
what you value,
what you chase,
who you want to be dealing with.
So these worldviews are very deep,
right?
And the,
and they can be partially cultural and there's a lot of neurobiology that says
some of this may actually be hardwired.
I don't want to go there because then you start getting into eugenics.
But the notion is we are a combination of our biology and our history and our
experiences,
right?
So there's problems.
Let me tell you a problem this comes with with anyone who's been married for a
long time will tell you that.
Can you change the other person?
Now you're all young and you think you can,
can you check I,
you just have to tell you as I'm,
I'm a pod from the future,
you're not going to change the other person.
The number one year for divorces,
when it's your one,
your one,
what you figure out in year one,
they're not going to change.
You either can live with this or you can't.
That's it.
So why am I telling you this?
Because you're going to try and change these people and you can't.
So what's the problem when you get the reds in your group,
what do they always do?
They're very judgmental.
They'll tell you the right way and the wrong way to do things right.
When you get the Greens in the groups,
what do they do?
They have no discipline.
They get up and walk away.
They don't follow up.
They have bad methodologies.
What are the blues?
The Blues loved to take over the blues of Ghana.
They can be boring or I'm good,
but here's what we should do.
Short term,
let's make the meeting five minutes.
It's like a drive by shooting,
Bang,
PowerPoint slides everywhere because they can't speak in complete sentences yet.
Right?
And finally,
when you get the yellow,
it's all about,
oh,
we can pull together and we can do,
let's just have another meeting.
The notion is you're gonna try and change that.
You can't.
This is the downside that goes with the upside.
This is what you have to deal with.
Nation states also have this challenge.
Now every nation state has all four of these Indian.
The whole idea of it,
of nation states.
Kind of an old idea,
but think about Japanese culture.
Why were the Japanese so good at quality after the war when we invented
basically invented quality six sigma in New York,
right?
So what's been interesting is the Japanese had a 2000 year old tradition of Hari
design.
This is part of their culture,
right?
Think about the Netherlands.
My name is the graph,
right?
The Netherlands.
How has the Netherlands been able to have this incredible,
prosperous a community?
It's a really small country.
The tallest country in the world.
If you know this,
I'm,
I'm but not representing,
well,
my mother is Hungarian.
But the notion is because things have gone well after the war because the Dutch
can't compete on scope or scale.
So they have to go out and trade.
They have to invent stuff,
right?
Think about the United States.
How did we get to be the United States?
You either came here to chase gold mountain,
you came to escape desire.
You came here and chains or you thought you were here,
right?
It was not exactly a picnic,
That's how we do things.
Rather ballistically and finally think about China where they're over 50 words
in Chinese for which uncle are you?
Are you the rich uncle?
Are you the crazy uncle?
The uncle?
We avoid the uncle.
We saw cop too.
Who are you in the family?
The notion is you're always going to see this and what happens is we have a
tendency to vilify the people who aren't like us,
right?
Instead of understanding them and that becomes the big challenge.
So we have to have the right person at the right job.
Now I'm going to take,
I'm going to throw some self help stuff out the window.
It's going to upset you,
but I'm going to tell you what basically the research says.
First off,
the assumption of type doesn't mean competency.
Oh,
I'm an artist,
but you suck,
right?
You're just not a good artist.
The assumption that talent can be developed,
this is my favorite one.
It can be developed to a point,
but you're not going to make Mozart or Michael Jordan.
Those are things that are a confluence of natural talent and the situation that
they find themself in assumption that all types of Rico,
they're not.
If I'm an investment banker,
what am I trying to do?
I'm trying to do blue stuff.
If I'm a university professor,
I'm trying to do yellow stuff.
So the blues are going to be more valuable in one situation,
the Elos and another,
and finally the assumption that balance is better.
Not necessarily.
So when I'm starting a project,
the Greens are genius because they love the ambiguity,
makes stuff as they go along.
At the end,
the reds are geniuses and everybody in between is a,
is a genius.
Now remember I haven't spoken about the exercise exercise.
What they're geniuses at is connecting boomers and millennials.
Xers are the smallest generation,
but they're the most ambidextrous generation we've seen.
So the only reason I talked about boomers and millennials is where the largest
generations by far relatively extra smaller Gen z are going to be smaller,
but they might be the most valuable,
right?
And incidentally,
millennials,
remember this,
there's more of you now than there are of us.
You're on the sunny side of the hill and if you ever figure that out
politically,
boy,
it's going to get real interesting real fast,
right?
So the direction you move under stress is what people really are.
So if you really want to know what somebody is,
see what they do,
and they're really under stress.
Do they go get on social media,
talk to friends?
Did they shorten the field and sort of look at the three things in front and
they look at the data,
you know,
do they go to weasel out of stuff to sort of go off the reservation and do all
kinds of creative stuff that will tell you what that person is.
But here becomes the,
the money part of this.
This is the key part.
How you innovate is what you innovate.
You want radical innovation.
You've got to embrace the artist.
You want to get scale.
You got embraced the engineer,
you want to go fast,
you got embraced the athlete,
you want to build some sustainable,
embraced the sage,
and you need all four of these to win.
So here's the biggest problems you're gonna run into and we're going to talk
about the data in one second on this.
The biggest problem you have is that the people who are in the green position
are orphans.
The artists are orphans.
You know the city that you're in right now.
And Arbor has more venture capital per person than any city in the United
States.
The problem is,
does it relate to anything else in this state?
No,
you're orphans.
So the problem is you got to snuggle up to people who are trying to make a
living and do things in other areas.
The second problem are the blues and the yellows,
and the problem is they're oppositional dogs and cats.
So one,
you have to really engage the conflict.
And the second problem is,
this is by far the longest cycle of innovation is sometimes called death valley
or the bottom of the bathtub.
How many Ben and a project that lost momentum?
Anybody been on a project that lost momentum and he sorta,
and you have to platoon players in and out.
Yeah,
this is that part.
If finally the reds,
the engineers,
the problem is they're so optimized that there's no room to try anything else.
And so when the new thing shows up,
they're not prepared for the new things because every moment of their life is
basically taken up.
So we have to rely on each other.
Now.
The other thing that's very important about the dynamics,
which is a key point,
is innovation doesn't move from the inside out.
Moves from the outside in,
and think about this for a minute.
When do people really change?
When do you really change?
I mean really?
Yeah,
when you made a mistake,
when your life sucks,
when you get divorced,
when you lose a job,
when your house goes away,
somebody close to you passes away.
Why do you change when your life sucks?
Because the risk of trying something radical and the reward of seeing where
you're at is reversed in a crisis.
Everybody falling us whether this is apple trading at $3 a share in 1997 right?
Whether this is Gandhi and the march to the sea,
it also has a negative effect.
This is also Hitler in the Brown shirts.
The notion is it doesn't move inside out.
It moves outside in where the middle of the organization is trying to do what?
Maintain and the outside is trying to do what?
Introduce diversity.
Now,
the other time that people change is when,
when they're on a roll,
you win the lottery,
you got promoted your nerve,
all that stuff.
Why do you try stuff then?
Because the same thing,
the risk of trying something radical and the reward of where you're at is
reversed,
right?
It's called risk capital,
In our world,
and instantly Google,
you've had a lot of risk,
capital flight pass,
10 years,
lot of risk capital.
So the notion is don't launch innovation from the inside out because what will
happen to that innovation is what the organization will begin to converge it.
It begin to make it more incremental.
You have to start at the perimeter.
The farther away you can be from headquarters,
the farther you can be away from the watchful eye,
the better off you're going to be.
Now this leads us to this last slide here.
This is referred to as,
um,
as the Schumpeter cycle and the Schumpeter cycle.
I want you to think about this for a minute.
Um,
first of all,
organizations are created by Greens.
Typically they want it.
They want to have freedom.
This is your,
this is Larry and Serge created in a garage in Menlo,
right?
This is what this was,
but next we got to get money involved and these are the people who gave you
money early on,
right?
These are the big,
the,
these are the big Apollo funds and things.
It gave Google money at the very beginning and they focus the two.
Then what happens is you grow ballistically.
We got to get the yellow's on board because we've got to have the right people
sell the right people,
build the right community,
and then we have to have ultimately the reds on board because we have to get to
scale somebody following us.
Now,
what's important about this,
once we get to scale,
the problem is every capital committee person,
every metric that we've got,
every,
uh,
process that we've run is designed to do what?
To deviance
to eliminate it.
Why didn't,
why didn't series become Amazon?
Why didn't Microsoft Become Google?
Right?
Why didn't Mcdonald's become Starbucks?
It had nothing to do with competition.
They had all the stuff in the lab,
right?
You know this,
the notion is,
and this is the radical part of this whole discussion,
what Schumpeter said is radical and whether it depends on who you're talking to.
We had six or seven Nobel prize winners in economics.
It's 90 69 I've talked about this.
The radical part of this is that what Schumpeter said is that we're not
destroyed by competitors.
For chump hater said is we kill ourselves.
We have seen the enemy and he is us.
Our dominant logic becomes so strong we can't get over it,
right?
And as a nation state in America,
aren't we suffering from this right now that we can't get over our dominant
logic,
we can't see the other.
He calls this the point of creative destruction.
And ironically,
organizations that begin to fail quickly have a much better chance of innovating
because they have to go back to the beginning of the cycle.
Apple trading at $3 a share,
somebody following us.
But think about General Motors in 1950 had 53% of the world car market drip,
drip,
drip.
It's called flatlining.
So the notion is there's an interesting sort of confounding a part to this where
even though there's tension,
the best thing that can happen is when one,
a cycle shifts into the other cycle in a relatively straightforward way.
So we can put cause in fact together.
So here's what,
here's the thing to do and then going to turn this over to standing.
She can talk about the book and what you can do here in your work.
Stop believing you can see the future.
Make smaller,
wider bets,
choosing big over fast.
No,
pick up your pace.
Go faster,
right?
Mistaking your managers for innovators.
Know,
encourage,
encourage and support your Weirdos.
We need Weirdos.
And incidentally,
if you're an organization that's really green,
Weirdos are reds,
everybody following us.
If you're a total,
if you're a yellow organization,
the Weirdos are blue.
They're just not like you having more ambition than capability,
right?
Talent matters.
You got to go out and build on the capability you have.
I love what the armed forces say.
You don't fight with army.
You want,
you fight with the army you have.
Right?
Which I think is great.
Starting at the center,
move out.
It's not student body,
right?
It's a perimeter game.
I worked on a project that you know that was originally called [inaudible].
If you know what is coke zero worked on coke zero.
The problem with coke zero was everybody thought they had it right and they
launched it to c two.
We had to move it out of site,
work it out off Broadway and bring it back and that became coke zero.
Um,
listening to the wrong people,
don't listen to the customers.
Who are your big customers because are they going to move first?
They can move last.
Finally failing to connect the dots.
You got to connect the dots.
That's why we're here.
You got to put all four
of these together.
Now,
the last part of this,
I want standing to come up and talk about this.
I want to talk about the book and the four steps in the book and what you could
do to actually engage the constructive conflict.
I got it.
Hey,
so what?
I won't bore you now.
I won't take too long,
but we'll be created.
But for speedy simple steps for you guys to create a constructive conflicts
because the thing about it is you actually have to do this every day.
It's,
it's not once you get,
it's almost like a muscle.
They,
that you have to exercise.
Once you got it,
it becomes really easy.
But if you've never done it before,
it can be pretty awkward and can be quite difficult and actually quite,
um,
quite intimidating to start first.
So what the first thing that you have to do is really assembled diversity of
perspective.
What I love about this building that's got to give us a tour.
If there's so many spaces here,
they're very open spaces that anybody can just go to.
So that's the first thing is,
you know,
I always talk to our clients and I will say there has to be a space where people
actually can just go in and just talk to one another,
like a normal human being.
If you put them just in cubicles and there's no way for them to go anywhere,
how are they actually going to meet at the people.
But this also talks about recruiting,
you know,
Aina Company.
You can't just recruit one type of person or one type of skill.
You might want to combine,
you know,
the skills you looking for with the kind of age you're looking for with,
the kind of skin color you're killing four with the kind of background with the
kind of do you know,
diversity of thought.
Where's this person coming from?
So it once you,
you have to have a pool of people in which you can communicate on a regular
basis.
And I think this is what Jeff always talks about is,
you know,
I,
we have three children and my youngest is 16 and they're always in social media.
And what I do see and social media too is,
um,
people start only looking and you know,
my friends are my friends and my friends have the similar view that I do.
And I get frustrated when I see like in a different point of view.
That to me was attacking my point of view.
I don't like that.
And I know people do that.
You know,
we,
we have our own niches and that's actually quite dangerous for what we want to
do.
You know,
we should just open up and start talking,
have a conversation with somebody else who's very different from us.
Um,
I was just talking to my intern and she was talking about how do you meet New
People?
And I said,
well I used to just to go to cafes and then a lot of people come cause this is
like I've never met any new person in a cafe.
I'm like,
it's totally different world now.
I totally get that.
But I think that's why you like you have to have to make the first step.
And um,
so this is like the kind of types of the four colors that you can find useful.
The engineers are very organized so they can be scientists,
analysts,
those kinds of things and seizures are teachers and so forth.
So you can look at that.
But the second step is then you have to actually engage it.
So we are talking,
but if we're doing brainstorming for example,
to solve a particular idea how a particular challenge in your organization,
you know,
gather everybody and make sure that it all four colors and then put in one
space,
one room and then just engage.
You actually have to talk.
This is what I was talking about.
If you do not,
if you do not agree with something,
that's it.
I don't agree with that.
You don't have to be mean.
You can be respectful,
but you have to engage in I think,
um,
and forgive me if I'm wrong,
but I also noticed that in my children,
especially at the 16 year old,
he's,
he doesn't like conflict.
So he doesn't like telling people I don't agree with you.
And it's easy for him to do in social media and to write something about instead
of just walking to the person and say,
I really disagree and this is actually a skill that you have to do.
You actually have to engage that with this open mindedness and conversation is
really when we,
when we create a cognitive dissonance in our brain and then we start thinking
about new things.
So one of the things that we also talk about is talk about like use this and say
what worked and what doesn't work and go through the four callers to see what's
working,
what doesn't right now and to figure out what solutions we can we can come out
with.
And when you get into a really big conflict and you feel like your stock,
the third thing that you have to do is really make sure that you establish that
shared goal,
a vision.
Keep already mining everyone.
Why are you there?
Why are you in this room?
We are trying to solve that particular problem and just kind of stick with it
because I,
if everybody has the same goal and everybody agrees with that same goal and they
can remove their ego,
I think that's a big thing from the um,
from the situation.
Do we might be able to come out with something.
And um,
the,
the fourth one is just,
then you have to construct the hybrid solution.
So brainstorm a lot of eraser could ideas and select the best ideas from the
four colors and try to see,
can I put the green one with the Red One?
Could I put the blue one in the yellow one and we put some up some ideas and
some assets in the book.
You can use metaphors,
you could use different kind of a creativity idea and that we can put up
together and basically the idea is last night compromise,
let's not choose one idea to another house to figure out a way that we can
ascend all this,
get all disagreement together,
but listen to one another,
create a bond and learn how to communicate with another and then come out with a
better solution.
Jeff.
Oh,
well
thank you.
Let's finish up here.
So what's the point?
Take a higher point of view,
right?
It's hard,
isn't it?
It's hard with all of the,
the,
all the anger.
It's hard to get to a higher point of view.
But do you,
have you noticed people,
adults are starting to do that now they're starting to say,
you know,
even though I might be a little bit on this side of the center line,
the people who are a little bit on the other side is settle.
I make a lot of sense.
We can have a conversation about that.
And finally I want you remember the digraph hypothesis,
which is probably what they'll remember.
How my tombstone,
out of all the stuff I've done in my life,
the amount of innovation and organization
produces is inversely related to the number of stupid PowerPoint slides or
elaborate process to high ground.
It makes about innovation in the,
in the old,
uh,
words of Phil Knight.
You just have to do it.
So I want to take us first.
I want to thank you for having us here.
I want to take a second.
It takes some questions if we could.
I know we're a little over time,
but I want to take questions because I know that this is a,
a very country,
uh,
a very,
counter intuitive view of how innovation works.
And what we didn't talk about here,
I took it out of the slide deck is we,
I did a number of,
uh,
we did a lot of analysis on the stock market is what it came down to starting in
1993 more effectively in 2000 in 2010.
And we started looking at these kind of indicators for contrarian,
uh,
points of view and what happened with the organizations that had a high scores
in these opposite areas.
It turns out that they outperformed everybody else in this growth index that
we've talked about that to almost no one's beat.
I think we've only lost with like a half a dozen times over the years.
So the notion is it's more than just a typology or a style.
There's really sort of an analytical engine underneath that.
So with that,
let's take some questions.
So push back please.
Cute.
So here in the office were broken up between floor.
Yup.
And those correspond to the different verticals that we support.
Um,
across North America,
um,
on my floor,
there's a lot of innovation that happens because we have a lot of freedom to
pitch an idea to pitch a project and run with it.
And I'm wondering,
given your hypothesis and the studies you've done,
how can leaders or owners of projects best identify these opposite colors?
Um,
to best,
I guess to make the best team?
Yeah,
I think that the easy answer to that is see what people do under stress or
duress.
And that's was that kind of throwaway slide I had.
But if,
if you've got somebody who's primarily a sage,
they're going to be extroverted.
They're going to be highly interactive.
So when they have a problem,
they're going to consult other people.
Right.
When you've got somebody who's a,
who is an athlete,
when they get a problem,
what they'll do is they'll shut other people out there.
The opposite of team people that take a lot of ownership and they'll,
they'll get rid of things in their life.
You'll notice it's like spring cleaning and they'll focus on one or two things.
They're very goal oriented.
When you're looking at somebody who's um,
who's an engineer,
they'll want to go back and look at the data and they'll think sequentially
about the data and they'll think about sort of combing through where the error
was and how to appreciate how to fix the air.
And if you've got somebody who's agreeing,
they'll talk.
What you'll see them do is look for escape routes.
They're kind of wiggly.
Does this make sense?
Because they're very imaginative.
They know how to tell a tale and interesting way and they'll try and escape.
So when I look at people,
one of the things I pay close attention to is what do people do when they're
stressed out?
Does this make sense to you?
And if you really want to make things successful,
I think the big thing is what we constituted success.
So one of the things I noticed in places like Google is people when they do a
small experiment or high lakes is successful because it's very,
it's a very artist organization.
The real question becomes what?
How does that make it into something that's scalable?
And the irony of Google is what,
and this is sort of the hard truth of this,
you have all these different businesses,
how many make money?
How many of the businesses make money?
It's already filing us.
Yeah,
I don't think we don't know.
Right?
And the notion is those are places that have effectively engage the reds and the
blues,
right?
So there's gotta be a place,
and this was the problem when I was young in my,
it was a,
I was an advisor,
was called applied integrated systems at apple.
The problem with apple in the beginning of days was it was very much like here,
but they couldn't figure out how to make money and they couldn't figure how to
get quality sorted out.
Just make sense.
So when jobs came back,
what did he learn?
He learned how to make money and get quality sorted out.
So this is the issue of,
it can be successful,
but to be successful all the way through the cycle,
you have to look for these different types.
Now there's a,
there's a place in the book you can go and take the assessment.
There's all kinds of material online.
If you go to,
if you go to a enough atrium.org or [inaudible] dot com there's tons of stuff I
think I've written over the years,
like 800 articles.
You know a lot of books and there's a lot of tools on there and no one,
all of her bother you.
But the notion is if you want to do something more with,
if there's a way to do that with,
there's a card game.
Yeah,
I could give some,
I have some card games.
If you want a car,
I'll give you a card game when we're done here and what's fun about the car
game?
Just ask a person to pick a card and tell me what your insanely great at and
people are pretty self aware.
They'll go,
I'm insanely great at this.
Go Great.
That's great.
Have someone else pick a card.
You're the opposite.
Okay.
The two of you are now going to work on this.
Now here's the challenge.
The real challenge cause we do this everyday in the innovation labs,
some of the biggest innovations that people write about,
the biggest challenge is keeping the conflict constructive.
Right?
And I put it to you this way or what I call big Jeff Days and little Jeff days,
big Jeff days.
I'm very open to constructive conflict.
Little Jeff days.
You ever get in that mood where you're like,
Oh God,
I can't,
I can't deal with this person today.
Now I'm,
and I'm not rude and I'm not going to fight in a negative way.
I'm just going to disengage.
I'm going to say today,
today,
you know,
there's a lot stuff going on in my life and I love you and I want to work with
you.
But today I'm taking a holiday.
I'm,
I'm getting off the grid today.
So part of it is knowing to do that.
I think it's also good life skill when you have a partner,
right?
Someone else,
he's so,
uh,
you talked a lot about the power of tension and the creative power of
constructive conflict.
And,
uh,
I think most people would agree that America is in a heightened state of tension
and divide it sure is.
So I'm curious what you would recommend or how can we harness this tension
productively?
I think,
uh,
it's sort of the opposite of the bell curve.
I think what's happening is actually twofold.
First of all,
I think the conflict that we're having is a conflict that we've needed to have
since the 1980s.
And the way I would characterize the conflict is when I looked at the,
before the election,
I was at one of the big government agencies to giving this talk.
Um,
it's,
I'm not trying to be political,
I'm trying to illuminate something here.
Um,
and I said,
I thought that Trump may very well when the election,
which of course was contrary to every set.
And they said,
why?
And it's thinking about Kurt who got blown out after the Oh oh eight recession.
There were,
there were four groups that got blown out.
The first group of young people,
you guys got blown out.
It was bad.
It's really bad.
The second was old people who are on retirement.
They got blown out and I,
the penny drop when I was at,
uh,
I walked by a Bernie rally here on campus and I'd never seen young people with
old people before.
This was like,
and I pay attention.
I'm one of those guys,
pays a lot of attention to incongruities and went,
wow,
well think about it.
Those are two groups that are one end of the bell curve.
They got blown out.
The other groups,
they got blown out where people of color,
all right,
think about all the,
all the,
the groups in the United States and a lot of those groups didn't vote.
They disengaged,
right?
Look at the numbers and then I need you to think about,
um,
people who look like me,
who are from neighborhoods like where I'm from.
And they'd been downwardly mobile since about 83.
And the notion is there real economic power,
you know,
their lack of education,
their mortality rate,
look at anything right now and those numbers.
And they were really mad out of all of those groups,
only one of them voted to make sense and they voted big.
Right.
So when we start looking at the numbers,
what I,
what I looked at was who's actually going to act,
which is innovation questions.
It's making sense to you.
Yeah.
So now the opposite of that is how this will come together is you start looking
at the middle of the bell curve and you draw a line.
What's happening is reasonable people,
which constitute about the 80% of the middle are starting to talk to each other.
So I think about being in a business school,
business school is filled with a lot of University of Chicago people,
very conservative economic,
they read the Economist every day and the journal,
it's a little right for me,
you know,
and then there's other people in the school,
read the,
you know,
read the Times every day.
Bloomberg,
everyday,
little left.
I read the post,
I'm kind of down that sort of that guy down the middle.
But,
but the notion is you're starting to see those people come together.
The majority is this making sense to you?
And they're starting to say,
we're going to have to take care of some of these things that we haven't taken
care of.
So there are issues,
there are social issues and there are economic issues.
And both of those issues,
I believe what you're starting to see is that come together.
I think what'll happen is this will be horribly painful for the next 18 months
for both sides.
Nobody is going to win this,
but it's a,
it's a,
it's a kitchen.
It should have started as a kitchen discussion and it's now a fight that's kind
of calming down.
That's my interpretation of what's happening.
And I think at the end of this,
and then this is cause remember conflict,
even if it's not constructive,
will often result in innovation.
I think we will have to get to a new place is that somebody's following this.
So that's my take on it.
But I,
I can imagine being young and seeing this ring side,
it's,
uh,
it's not any,
and it's,
and it's when people compare this to,
uh,
just drop the comparisons to Hitler or to Watergate,
these,
this is a whole different animal.
And,
and I think a lot of those metaphors or analogies are don't work.
I think we're looking at a world that's connected both vertically and
horizontally.
And I think the horizontal connections are so much stronger in your generation.
I think it's going to be very different.
Thank you.
Anyone else?
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
what's your perspective on the historical cycles of innovation?
even in terms of nostalgia as an example this year when all this turmoil people
are looking back to the 1980s,
things like that,
what do you think about as the deck?
Yeah,
I'd like to say that I don't think they exist,
but I do think they exist.
Um,
here,
here's,
there's is a very famous book written at the end of the 18 hundreds,
um,
by Oswald Spangler and Spangler.
Basically,
it's a book's called the decline of the West.
And Spangler is this German academic who basically gets it.
He's really,
he starts showing what's going to happen.
And what's amazing is he predicts the first world war and the Second World War.
And the reason it predicts him is he understands the cycle.
So he's looking at cycles and economies happen in cycles.
So,
um,
so the part that I would say I disagree is that we're in a very different
accelerated age with all of this horizontal,
what I call longitude connection,
the network world,
Nile for Neil Ferguson's new book,
you know,
the square and the tower,
right?
That stuff.
And I think that's true,
uh,
at least to some degree,
I think the other,
but the other thing is human nature's human nature.
And what happens in human nature is you develop a,
a theory of,
of,
of a new theory of governance.
And over time that theory,
uh,
decays into the very thing that tried not to do.
This is what vapor wrote about.
1984.
This is what Orwell wrote about.
The animals are all gonna be equal and then baby come Stalinist right.
Does this make sense to,
so yes,
I think there is something to cycles.
I think predicting when people start predicting how many years they're going to
be like the Russians do or how big you're going to be,
then I think it gets a little iffy.
It my making sense.
So,
so in summary,
yes,
I think there are cycles,
but I think the cycles are a little less predictive than people think they are.
Did I answer your question?
What do you think?
Cause that's my question.
I think I think that when innovation happens for a few years,
people accept that all this change happened and then maybe calm down for a few
years because they're riding the wave of the changes that took place.
You know,
technology birth.
Did you read?
Um,
the woman's name is Jackson.
She's the CEO or not CEO,
the president of Rensler polic technique.
Did you read her book on innovation cycles?
She basically point something out that I think is very damning.
She said that most of the wave,
which your company was built on was w sort of ended in the mid nineties and that
what we've been doing is iterations of that wave for a long time.
And I know that when people start talking about like collaborative open
innovation networks,
I worked on apple net,
which became iTunes.
I mean that's what,
84 85 right?
You start thinking about what people talk about is now the innovator.
IOM was built 10 years before we work.
So the notion is when you start looking at where the genesis of things are and
you pick like,
you know where this is really fun music,
right?
I grew up in the 70s and people went to high school in the 70s and you know,
people say,
well,
you know,
what happened to you give all the music genres that people listen to now and
they all happened in the 70s is this making sense to you?
So the nineties the nineties for technology,
seventies for music,
the issue becomes at what point is that long cycle done right?
And usually it has to be disruptive to be done.
But you're,
I think you're seeing disruption.
I come back to what I talked about.
Maybe you weren't in the room.
We talk about the structure,
disruption of institutions.
You know,
marriage is different now.
Religion is different now.
Um,
what work is,
is different now.
Universities will soon be different now trust me,
they will.
Madison will be different now.
And I think those are more subtle long cycles.
Anyone else?
One more,
kind of going back to what you're talking about with like contrarion indicators
and how you saw that these companies far out performed any others.
Yup.
Um,
I was wondering if you had any insight is how we can distill that down and take
that back to like our teams put that to work for us.
Um,
I think what I would recommend is I'd read the book,
right?
And I'd say,
uh,
one of the things that,
that the book will give you clues about this,
some of this,
obviously I can't open up the whole can of worms here,
so I don't want to over commit to something.
But you'll notice that there are list of attributes that could easily be turned
into key indicators that you could follow.
And then I'd ask you to do some of your own research to say,
well if you get some of these contrary and key indicators,
and I think it's uh,
pardon?
Can you answer that?
Yeah,
thank you.
Okay.
I can speak a little bit toward that.
So
we wanted to see if the culture differences in the four quadrants,
the four colors would,
it would appear all sign per company performances.
So we looked through 20 years of data.
But what's interesting to me when we looked at the companies who do well over
there,
it's again,
it's like they do well red and green and then blue and yellow.
And when four of them are showed up at the same time,
that's better.
So you can be very good at blue can,
you can,
you can be very good at craney couldn't be the in red,
but when you're good at both your value,
it's multiplied.
That's what I'm trying to say.
So what does that mean?
When I saw the data,
the data,
the hard data actually is telling me that you have to have your basics down.
So,
and this is specialty good for you guys for Google because you,
you were at based on algorithm,
so your reds out to be very,
very strong.
But then on top of that you have to these loose process,
these,
you know,
groups of people who,
who can take it to the next place to look at future growth.
But it is in this combinations.
I think in particular more,
uh,
from my research look much more relevant and much,
much more vibrant than the youth.
The blue and yellows have to hold it together.
But for me,
the,
what I saw,
mostly it's the red and green.
I also think if you go back and look at some of the earlier books that I've
done,
there's a lot of clues in there about very specific things to measure.
Obviously it gets a little more,
we're making this overly simple to make the concept accessible cause there's a
lot of interdependencies.
There's a lot of complexity under the hood,
just like Your Business,
right?
It's some of the stuff is of great interest to Wall Street and not to normal
people and some stuff's not more interest to people or governance.
If you read the book and the next step is maybe read this book leading
innovation,
which I wrote,
I don't know,
15 years ago,
then I think the interesting thing would be that if you have some,
you run it for a while,
I'd be interested to see how I'd be interested to hearing from you what happens,
what you find right.
That would be of interest to me,
making stone soup has a really great formula to it.
Yeah.
There's a thin book that I wrote that we wrote for jump starting in the labs.
I did,
if you know this,
the University of Michigan as a certified professional innovator program,
which we created,
right?
So that's the first certificate program they ever did with the school of
Engineering.
Right?
Uh,
we wrote a book for it called making stone soup and it's uh,
I think it's like $7 and eight at your,
you know,
on the android.
It's all,
but it's,
it's a,
it's a great way to start.
That's a great point,
Lindsey.
It's a great way to start CEC,
CEC.
We start so that,
like I said,
the challenge of this is,
it's so easy that people think it's like a,
a disc test or a Myers Briggs test.
The challenges,
if you start going down that road,
what I'm suggesting to you is you start by a beginner,
you read as a beginner,
but if you want to go all the way down the road,
I mean,
there's something you could do also with just the resources that are publicly
available,
I can get a lot more sophisticated,
a lot faster.
Anything else?
Thank you.
I appreciate you Hagen out here to the end.
I,
uh,
and good luck with all this and thanks for having us out.